-Oh, yes.
Oh, it's so good to be here.
Look at me out here
dressed like Ellen.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, man. I'm celebrating 'cause
today marks 23 years
of me being not sober.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
And if you're sober,
I'm a people pleaser,
so, oh, my God, me too.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sober for several hours
a day.
And then the day gets better.
I have friends that judge
my drinking.
They're like,
"You know, that stuff
will take years off your life."
I'm like,
"Eh, not the good ones."
[ Laughter ]
Come on, I'm not going to treat
these good years hoping to get
those years where I lose control
of my bodily faculties,
I forget everything, and I fall
down everywhere I go
when I can enjoy all of that
right now.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks to drinking. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I trust drinkers.
They're fun, you know?
I saw a guy with a hat
on the other day.
It said, "I'm an alcoholic.
My favorite thing in the world
is drinking outdoors
and I want everyone to know it."
Well, it didn't say all that.
It just said "Yeti."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But that's what it meant.
Come on, nobody loves "coolers"
that much.
[ Laughter ]
That's like somebody
who loves nose candy
wearing a hat that says
"mirrors."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
I have the body of a drinker.
I got a little tummy.
I shouldn't have a tummy.
I take long walks almost
every single morning,
you know, to go get my car.
And --
[ Laughter ]
But, no, I have a little tummy.
I got a double chin.
Does anybody in here have the --
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, look at me.
I'm Chinning Tatum. You know?
[ Laughter ]
But I like my double chin.
It keeps me safe, right?
You couldn't put me in
a headlock, right?
Try to put me in a headlock.
You'd be like, "I got ya."
I'd be like, "Nope."
[ Laughter ]
Couldn't do it.
[ Applause ]
You couldn't do it.
And I'm not a bad-looking guy.
From here on up, you're like,
"Oh, who's that?" You know?
Right? But here I just got this
going on.
I always look like you took
a photograph of
a super-good-looking guy right
when he was at
the down bounce of
a diving board.
[ Laughter ]
Like yes, yes, no.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah. Ah, thank you.
But you can't choose where
you store fat on your body.
Doesn't that suck? Right?
If I could choose, I'd store it
underneath my feet.
'Cause then when people are
like, "Dude, how fat are you?"
I'll be like, "6'4."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm so fat, I can dunk, bro."
I[ Laughter ]
It just feels good to be here.
It feels good to connect with
people again, you know?
I love connecting.
That's my favorite thing.
I was talking to this guy
after my show.
He was this big, burly
biker dude.
Teardrop tattoo, right?
We all know what that means.
I'm just trying to connect.
I'm like, "Ah, I've been
thinking about
getting one of those."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I am a cryer."
Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was like, "Have you seen
the movie 'The Notebook?'"
[ Laughter ]
"If you're a bird, I'm a bird."
Yeah, I like to choose kindness.
I'll tell you what.
I would never ghost a gal.
Do you guys know what
ghosting a gal is?
[ Laughter ]
Well, there's lots of different
variations nowadays.
But traditionally speaking it's
where a man has sex with a lady
and afterwards
he never calls her,
texts her, or sees her again.
He just vanishes like a ghost.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, well, let me tell you
what, fellas.
Don't do that.
That is rude business.
Put the power in her hands.
Don't ghost. Smother.
[ Laughter ]
It's way more effective.
Next time you have sex with that
lady for the first time,
she falls sleep next to you,
send her an accidental
text message.
Send her a text message that
says,
"Hey, Mom, think I met the one."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
"I can't be too sure, but I'm
watching her sleep right now."
[ Laughter ]
As soon as she wakes up, as soon
as her peepers flutter open,
your head needs to be right
there and go, "Hey, guess what."
And she'll be like, "What?"
And you'll be like,
"Forever starts right now."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah. Yeah.
You'll be single like that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Don't ghost. Haunt.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright, you guys, I'm Pete Lee.
Thanks for being a great crowd.
Thank you very much.